よろしくお願いします
今日は幸福ということについてお話させていただきます
幸福という言葉っていうのはね
大体世の中でよく溢れている言葉で
まあ誰でもその幸福について考えたり
幸福をつかまりたいと思って努力はしていますね
で まあ新約聖書でもね
その教え書いてるところは福音と訳していますからね
英語ではゴスペルという言葉なんですけど
日本訳は福音ですか いわゆる幸福のメッセージですね
まあこれを聞けば幸福になるというふうなイメージで
まあそういうふうに この
やっぱり幸福のことを喋っているんですね
大体宗教っていうのは
で そこでお釈迦様があの
まあ幸福というものは希望すること
願うこと 幸福のために努力することは
あの 生命の基本的な とても当たり前の
立場だと 当たり前の気持ちだと
ふうに考えておられたみたいですね
幸福の代わりに不幸を探す人よ
人はいないと 人というよりは生命の生命すべてですからね
不幸になろうではないかなと思う生命はいません
だから生命は何を探しているかというと
幸福というものを探しているんですね
ですから それは生命の
大変大事な 大変重大な
問題なんです 小さな問題ではないんです
ですから わかりやすく言えば
我々は何を探しているんですかと
結局幸福を探しているんですね
そういうわけで  一般的に人に聞けば
あんたは何のために生きてるんですかと
人はあまりこの人が答えられないんですね
はっきりと聞けばね あんた何のために生きてるんでしょうかと聞いたら
もうそんなにはっきりと答えられない
でも答えはもう何のために生きているわけではなくて
私は幸福を探してるんだと
それのために生きているんですね
ですから このせっかく生きているならば
幸福で生きていたいんだと
ですから この全ての生命の大変大事なこの課題でもある生きる衝動でもある
また生きる目的でもある
この幸福というのは何でしょうかと考えた方がよろしいんですね
この一般的な社会では
私たちは一応幸福を探しているんです
それなりに それなりに探している幸福をうまくいかないと
この探したんだけど失敗しましたと
あるいは自分にはこの幸福にはなりくはないかなと
そういうふうに思ったり考えたりする時もありますし
その時は大変混乱してすごく混乱して
生き方を間違ってしまっちゃうんですね
[背景音楽]大体この私たちは問題にしているのはそういう人々のことなんですね
生き方間違ってる人々
おかしくなってる人々
まあ変なことを言わ 変な屁理屈を言わ
社会人とうまく溶け合わないとかね
そういういろいろことがありまして
問題トラブル作ったりとか
混乱だけでね 精神的にすごい混乱に陥って
悩んだり苦しんだりする
で そういう人々がどんどんどんどん破壊的な行動に行くんですね
うまくいかないんだから
その怒ってしまって で
破壊しようと それで家族を破壊する
まず自分の両親 せっかく作った平和な家庭を破壊する
次に まあ自分の周りの友達やら学校の仲間やらね
そういう周りの人々を破壊する
まあ大人だったら社会のいろいろ迷惑をかけて破壊したりする
で 結局自分自身が廃寺になって破壊して
自分が破壊されてしまって
もう悲しく死んでしまっちゃうんですね
で そうなる人々っていうのは
結局この自分の道が間違ったかとかね
幸福を探していたんだけど
自分には自信がないとかね
うまくいかないとか なんとかもう感じた時なんですね
それは小さい時感じる可能性もあるし
若い時そういうことを感じる可能性もあるしね
大人になってから感じる可能性もあるし
せっかく頑張ったんだけど無駄でしたとわかったら
大人でもまあ平気で自分を殺してしまっちゃうんですね
自殺したりして そういうわけで
この幸福を探すということは大変大事なことなんですね
ですから 探すことも大事であるし
探す方法も大事でありますね
で ちょっと間違ったらもう大変危ないんです
幸福を探す道っていうのは
まああの それであの 幸福というのはね
どういうものかと なんで生命がそんなに必死になって幸福を探すのかと
ということ なぜ探すんですか？幸福
なぜ幸福になりたく そんなに必死になって努力頑張っているんでしょうかと
努力し 頑張るし 必死になって幸福になりたい
それなんででしょうか
なんでしょうかね まああの
よく考えると やっぱり
今私は幸福じゃないということがあるんです
今の状況で満足してないんですね
今の状況に満足していないんだから
やっぱりもうちょっと良くなればいいんじゃないかなと
今の状況に納得していないんですね
ですから もうちょっと良くなれば良いのではないかと
そういうことで探し求めているんです
ですから お釈迦様は あの
スカカーマニブータニという全ての生命が幸福を願っているんだと
欲しがっているんだとっておっしゃってはいるんです
スカというのは幸福 カーマニっていうのは好んでいる
ブータニっていうのは生命っていうことなんですね
生命が幸福を好んでいると
で いろんな経典でいろんな言葉で同じことを言ってるんですね
生命っていうのは幸福というものを願って好んでいるんだと
それはお釈迦様のもう一つの言葉がありましてね
すべての現象は いわゆる世界全体的に見ると
あるのは苦だけですよと
虚しさ 不満 それだけですよということと同じ言葉なんです
まあほとんどすべてのものは苦しみでありますよと
不安でありますよと 未完全で不安で不満なものだよと
存在も他の物事 そのことと生命が幸福を願っているよということも同じことなんです
なぜ全ての生命が幸福を願っているかというと
すべてのものは不満で不完全だからなんです
ですから このなんかおかしく
この全く正反対のように聞こえる言葉が似ているんです
お釈迦様はすべては苦しみだと言ったんではないかと
だから幸福のことを喋るのはおかしいではないかと思うかもしれませんだけど
でも結局言葉違ってあって意味が同じなんです
すべてのものは苦しみですから
やっぱりそれは何とかしたいと
苦しみは嫌ですよという気持ちは
どんな生命にも心の中にあるんです
ですから 私たちは頭の中で全ては苦しみであるということは否定しているんですね
頭で 頭で否定しているんだけど
心がものすごく強烈にそれをわかっているんです
大変苦しみだと ですから心は幸福を探せと叫んでいるんです
幸福をちょうだいと どんなことでも幸福になりましょうと
というふうに心が叫んでいるんです
なぜ心がそういうふうに叫んでいるか
全ては苦しみだからなんです
そこで問題は 幸福を探せと言うんだけど
その心自体が何が幸福かと経験したことがないんです
一度も 我々の心が一度も何が幸福だろうかと経験したことがないんです
だから全ては苦しみだから
聞くものも苦しみである
不安である 満足できない
見たものも満足できない
ご飯何を食べたっても満足できない
何があっても満足できないんですね
ですから 心は結局苦しみしか経験したことがないんです
だから 一度も経験したことがないものを心が欲しがって願って叫んでいるんです
欲しいと これ欲しいと
幸福が欲しい でも幸福があっても
これは幸福やとわからないんです
あってもわからない なぜならば
見たことも味わったこともないんだから
経験したことがないんだから
そこで我々に生きる世界で生きる上では
もう大きなトラブルが
大きな問題がまた生まれてくるんです
これすごい単純な理屈なんです
私は言っているのは あまり複雑に考えないでください
すごい単純簡単な理屈なんです
また順番で繰り返すというならば
全ての生命は幸福というものを願って欲しがっている
幸福は世の生命は誰もいません
なんでそんなに必死になって幸福を願っているかというと
全ては苦しみであるからなんです
今すでに幸福であるならば
探す必要ないんだからね
今すでに幸福じゃないんだから
それを探していると 心が叫んでいると
幸福になりましょうと叫んでいるんだけど
幸福は一度も味わったことがない
心が 一度も幸福になった経験がない
だから何が幸福かとわからないんですね
だから探しても探しても見つかりくはないと
そういうことで この輪廻転生として限りなく続くんです
限りなく探す 限りなくもう幸福を探す
探して見つからなかったら
ものすごく腹が立ってもうすごい混乱状態になっちゃって
精神分裂までして もう大変なことになるんですね
時々大量に破壊活動までしちゃうんです
とにかく幸福を探していくんですね
探しているんだけど 見つかりますかと
見つからないんですね
だからまあどうしようもない状態なんですね
そのシステムなんですね
お釈迦様 明確に我々に教えようとしているのは
何か探して 例えば我々は山に入って金を探そうとする
金脈なんかあれば大変金持ちになりますからね
それで金というのはどういうものかとわからない人が
見たこともない人が見つかるくはないでしょうね
もしあの山の中に入って穴を洞窟でも掘って
洞窟ではなくて 何て言いますか
このそういうあの土の中を掘って金脈を見つかりたければ
かなり金について知識が必要なんです
まず金を見たことがある
全部状況を知っている
だからといって そういう我々見るのような形で金は見つからないんです
自然の中で ただの土として
岩として見つかりますからね
そこでその金が入っている
そういうまあまあ 岩なんですかね
そういう なんています？そういうの
金鉱脈ですね まあそういう
あの まあほとんどまあ岩みたいなね
もので まあ土と一緒になってあって
そこら辺見て あ この中に金があるんだよと
それをまた持ってきていろいろ加工してたところで純金が出ますよというぐらい
あの知識がなければ見つからないんです
昔アメリカでもね この金を探すね
ゴールドラッシュといってね
まあ探すことがあったんだけどね
そこであの あの金だと間違う何か石があるみたいですね
すごくピカピカ光ってあって
であれはフールズゴールドという英語で
一般英語で言ってるんですね
で 知らない人がそこを見つかったら大喜びするみたいですね
ものすごく金のように輝くんだけど
全く金ではない あれは銅とか他の鉄とか混じっている他のものなんです
ですから やっぱりそういうピカピカと光っているものを見ても
それは金ではなく もう全然光っても何でもない
そのかっこ悪いこの土の中に金脈が入ってるんだよとよく発見しなきゃ金は見つからないんです
そういうことで 幸福を探す前に
かなり幸福ってどういうものかと研究しておかないと見つかるものではありません
このただ探す それでは意味がない
見つからないと そういうわけで
仏教ではこの大変厳密にどのようにすれば幸福を探せるかという道
仏道として教えているんですね
だから仏道はお釈迦様の教えはすべて人々に本当に幸福をつかめる方法を教えているんです
いろんな角度から ですから
かなり大変な研究に勉強にはならなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ そういうわけで ただそういうことで
仏教というのは結構まあ勉強簡単に楽に勉強しようかなと思っても
そうはできないかもしれません
まあそんなに甘く勉強できるものではないんですね
そこで文句言ったっても
これわかりやすく簡単に何で教えないかとかね
それはできないんですね
ですから しっかりと事実を知らなくちゃいけないんですね
しっかりと事実を知って
幸福を理解して 幸福の方法論を理解して
それを見つからなくちゃいけないんです
そこで科学的にお釈迦様は物事を見るんだから
我々に言うのは幸福を探す前に
なぜ我々は幸福を探しているんですかと
それを見ようではないかと
それは我々の苦しみを見ようではないかと
とことん何が苦しみかと
何が不安かと そこをよく理解すると
そこから離れればそれは幸福だと
それで仏教の方法論として掴む
掴む道ではなくて 捨てる道になっているんです
例えば幸福を掴むと そういうことは仏教的にならないんです
逆に苦しみをすべて捨てると捨てて何も掴めません
そこで幸福が成り立つ
幸福を掴んだ 握った 握った人間ではなくて
幸福というものは成り立つんだと
そこで握ったら まあ手を緩んだらもう逃げちゃうんですね
だから幸福をつかむものではないんです
力強く握るものでもないんです
もしつかんだら それは幸福ではないんですね
ちょっと手が緩んだら逃げてしまいますから
それで仏教として我々に出てくるのは
その徹底した苦しみの分析と苦しみの理解
まあそれで理解して そういういらないもの
苦しみになるもの 不満になるものを捨てて捨てていきましょうと
それで捨てて捨てていくと
やがて幸福というものは成り立つんだと
ですから仏教は 仏教の道が最終最終的な瞬間までも捨てては前に行くという道なんです
それで幸福というものは明確に成り立ちます
幸福を握ることではなくて
幸福というものは実現することはできます
いわゆる捨てるものは何もないということは
苦しみは一切ないということなんです
すごい論理的でしょうし
すごい簡単な論理なんです
そういう点で難しいとは言いにくいんですね
で 次のステップなんですけど
で あの 普通に私たちが何が幸福かとわからなくて
それでも探してるんですね
この探しているものは苦しみだけですよと
人々は探してつかむものは結局苦しみだけですよと
それはどういうことかと心がわからないんですね
もう味わったことがないんだから
経験したことがないんだから
幸福は だから これはおそらく幸福だろうと何か掴まってみる
掴まってみるところで
それは幸福じゃない それでまた不安が出てきて
じゃあ他のものを掴まってみようと掴む
いたらそこも幸福でなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうふうなことで
我々は幸福になろうと必死になって頑張ってはいるんだけど
なかなか心の中で幸福を感じられなくなっちゃうんですね
わかりやすい例にしましょう
例えば 人が幸福になろうと思って結婚する
結婚したところで なかなかこの二人がうまくいかない
互いにあまりうまく合わない
そこでいくらか努力はしますけど
やがて努力できなくなる
もう喧嘩だけになってしまう
互いに顔も合わせたくなくなっちゃう
それでまあ一緒にいれば不幸だと思って
まあ別れて離婚すると
離婚したらその二人のもう次の考え方なんですかね
もっといい人を見つかろうと
だから幸福になることはないんですね
だから いまだにその人が一回結婚して大変苦しみを味わっているにも関わらず
いまだにその人の心の中で結婚は幸せだとという概念があるんです
それでまあ番目の人を探すんですね
もっといい人という思う人がね
それでもっといいかどうかはわからないんだけど
まあもう誰かが探してるんだから
そこらへん見つかった誰かとまた結婚してしまっちゃうんですね
それで一緒になってみたら
もうまた合わないと で
また離婚する そういう風にあるでしょうね
だから離婚再婚やってる人々はこれ何回何回も繰り返しちゃうでしょうね
回目 回目とかね もう回も回も回以上結婚離婚したりする人々は世の中にいるんだからね
だからそういうね 例えば回結婚して回離婚したという人にしても
だから回もすごい苦しみを味わったでしょうね
だから あまりにも並ならぬ精神的な苦しみを味わったんだから離婚するんですね
なぜならば 結婚というのは一生一緒になりますよという約束で結婚するんだから
一生一緒に生きていますよと約束して
もう二度と顔も見たくないぐらい精神的に苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけない
それで離婚になる それ十回ぐらい繰り返しちゃいますからね
まあ皆様十回はできませんだけど
結構豊かなね お金ある人々の状態になっちゃったら
これも結構これ繰り返しちゃうんですね
もうかなりお金がないとね
そんなに一年一回ぐらい結婚して
また離婚してっていうことはできないんです
それにもすごくお金かかりますからね
ですから 一般の方々はまあちょっと経済的に不可能だからやらないだけで
気持ちから言えばもう回ぐらいでも離婚して再婚してみたいなという気持ちがあるんじゃないかなと思いますけど
そこは別にこの欲でも何でもないんです
本当はこの綺麗な女の人が見るたびに
あの女の人と結婚したいと
そういうのを思っていることでもないんです
なんかどこかでこれじゃないんだと
生活っていうのはもっと何か面白い
落ち着いている幸福な生活ないんじゃないかな
あるんじゃないかなと思って
その離婚 再婚 離婚 再婚という順番でやっちゃうんですね
ですから そういうもう何回も離婚
離婚 再婚する人々はあまりにも欲深いんだと言い切って捨てることはできませんです
それ 欲が深いか少ないかというわけじゃないんです
何か幸福というものを探してるんです
なら結婚してみたら何か違うんじゃないかなと
で そういうことで理解してみましょう
心が結局これは幸福だと最初にも決めつけちゃって
それを探す 中部経典の中に出てくる
この探す求めるという名前のタイトルの経典があるんです
それはこれとのタイトルは聖者の探求みたいなタイトルなんですけど
聖者が何を探すんですかと
そこにこの聖者でない一般の人々が何を探すかとまず書いてるんです
そこで聖者でない普通の人々が苦しんでるんだと
苦しみは仏教ではすごい厳密に言ってるんだから
この大雑把な苦しみは言わないんですね
大体苦しみっていうのは年を取ることを老いることですね
それで体が弱くなって醜くなること
いわゆる老人になることですね
それから病気になること
それから死んでしまうこと
全て捨てて死ななくちゃいけない
そういうものは誰にしたっても嫌なものなんですね
本当はその基本から他の苦しみが出ているんです
一般の人々はその基本が忘れてしまって
いい 別に私は年取ることは嫌ではないんだと
当たり前だから それじゃなくて
会社で給料はちょっと高くならないんだけど
それはちょっと苦しみだと
くだらないことを言うんですね
家族はみんなもうちょっと楽しくいればいいんじゃないかなと
それは私の苦しみだと
でもそういうのはあんまり大胆なことじゃなくて
基本的には年取ったり弱くなったりすることがものすごく嫌で
病気になることは嫌で
死ぬことは嫌で それを避けるために他のものを探してるんですね
なんでたくさんのお金が必要かといったらね
やっぱり体を守ってあげるためでしょうし
なんで守ってあげるかというと
早く死なないように守ってあげることだから
ですから 基本的な苦しみっていうのは
やっぱりまあ老いることと病気になることと死ぬことなんですね
そこでこのそういう苦しみが嫌で
人々はなんとか探さなくちゃいけないと
何か探すんだと 何を探すんですかというと
わざと老いるものを探すんだと
病気になるものを探すんだと
私は病気になりたくないがゆえに
病気になるものをいっぱい探して集まるんだっていうことなんです
私は死にたくない そのために一生懸命死ぬものは徹底的に探しますよということで探してるんだと
それでいくら探しても終わりがないと
この基本的な苦しみはなくならないんだと
それでさらに説明します
何を探すか 例えばお釈迦様が言うのは
この 財産探すんだと 昔風に言えば
土地やら牛やらニワトリやら
そういう家畜動物とかね
それは財産でしたからね
今だったらお金だけ財産ですけどね
昔はたくさん財産が人々にはありましたからね
ですから 土地を増やそうではないかと
たくさん牛を飼いましょうと
牛たくさんいればもう幸せだと
たくさん鶏を飼いましょうと
たくさん羊やら山羊やら飼っておこう
そうすると食べ物に苦しむことなく
まあ豊かな生活ができるんじゃないかなと
そこで苦しみが消えますかね
牛が１頭１頭増えると
どれぐらい楽しいですかね
牛１頭あれば まあ昔風に考えましょう
現代風ではなくて 昔の我々はね
昔に戻って 田舎で小さな家を作って
まあ生活しているんだ
そこでまあ牛乳とか飲みたくなると
で まあスーパーで売ってるわけじゃないんだからね
やっぱり牛１頭買うでしょうね
牛１頭買ったら まあそれでまあいくらかは牛乳を飲めるんですね
でも牛１頭買ったらどうなるんですかね
その牛の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですね
ずっと生き物だから まあ餌をちゃんと買ってあげなくちゃいけないし
まあそれなりに体洗ったり
とにかくまあそれなりに牛の面倒を見なくちゃいけないし
自分で乳を搾っておかないといけないし
もう大変仕事が増えちゃうんですね
そこで人間どう計算するかというと １
頭の牛の乳は牛乳足りませんから
やっぱり２頭にしましょうと ３
頭 ５頭 １０頭にしましょうとかね
そこでこの仕事はどんどん増えて増えて増えて
もう大変なことになるんですね
そこで１０頭２０頭ぐらい牛があると
他の仕事は一切できなくなっちゃうんですね
子供と遊ぶことでも何でもできなくなります
朝から晩まで牛の面倒を見ることになってしまっちゃうんです
まあそれはそれで住めばいいんですけど
牛は病気になるわ 早く死んでしまっちゃうわ
時々牛たちがいるんですね
よく餌食べさせちゃったら脂肪が溜まっちゃって
あの 何て言いますか 産めなくなっちゃうんですね
子牛を産まなきゃ乳を搾れませんからね
太ることは太るんだけど
それでまた大変でしょうし
そういうことでもうどんどんどんどん仕事は増える
苦しみが増える 肝心な自分考えてた幸福というものは遠ざかっていく
それだけじゃなくて 大変悲しみを味わったりするんですね
そういうものなくなったりすると
例えば自分に息子がいると
やっぱり息子に財産を残させなくちゃいけないんだと思ったりして
たくさん牛の数を増やしちゃおうとする
で 息子が見たら これ大変な仕事だから
苦しみだから私はやりたくないんだと言ったら
自分の息子まで脅さないといけないんですね
お前 うちの子だったらこれちゃんとやりなさいとか
それで可哀想に自分のすごい可愛がっている息子まで精神的にいじめたり脅したりまでするんですね
家の財産を守らなきゃ
あんたはもう息子でもなんでもないんだと
けしからん生き方ではないかと
あれ何言ってるんでしょうかね
幸福という概念 まるっきり頭にないんですね
そこにあるのは実際に苦しみだけ
その父親がいっぱい牛を持ってるんだと
で 威張っている本人に聞けば
これ大変苦しいんだけど
やっぱり息子には何か残っておかないと意味がないんだと
もうよく食べていられるために苦労しないように何か残しておかなくちゃいけないんだから
これぐらい大きく牛をたくさん買ったんだろう
そう思っても それは全くの事実と反しているんですね
もし父親があまりにも幸福で満たされているならば
もうそれだったら息子は全然反対しません
息子から見ても それ苦しみだけであって
なんで私も同じ苦しみを続けなくちゃいけないかと思っちゃいますけど
父親はそれも忘れて お前これ守らなきゃけしからんではないかと
何のために私は今まで苦労してきたんですかと
堂々と言うんです 何のために私は今まで苦労してきたんですかと
だから今まで苦労してきたんだから
息子にも同じこと言って
お前もこれからさらに苦労してくださいと
そこで幸福という概念
きれいに飛んでいってる飛んでるんですね
そういうわけで 一般の人々の生き方はもう幸福な道ではないんだと
なんかどこかですごいおかしく
変になっているんですね
で 現代風な社会に戻って
同じ例をね 牛のことをあまりわからないかもしれませんけど
でも皆様方 この北海道とかそこら辺に行ってみてください
この牛をちゃんと飼って育てている方々いるでしょうに
大変な重労働なんですね
大変な重労働 ものすごい朝早く起きなくちゃいけないし
で 朝すごく遅くまでまた仕事をしなくちゃいけないし
こんな会社に行ってるサラリーマンのような
そんな簡単単純なことじゃないんですね
牛が病気になってしまったら
もう馬やらね 飼ってる動物病気になってしまったら
これ冬の十二時であろうが三時であろうが関係なく起きて
お医者さんとかね 獣医さんを呼んで徹夜して面倒見なきゃ死んでしまっちゃいますよ
そんな簡単なこの会社の仕事みたいな
このオフィスレディーみたいなおしゃれしてね
もう朝行って夜帰ると
そんな楽な仕事じゃないんです
おしゃれなんかする暇は瞬間ではないんです
それぐらいこの大変な仕事なんです
で それで じゃあ私たちはじゃあ現代
都会から考えてみる 見て
人が会社作ったと 会社作ったら
まあ給料よりはたくさんお金あった方が幸福だと
会社作ってしまったらどうなるんでしょうかね
これも同じく大変な苦しみになってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで会社を成長することだけで精一杯で
一日でも自分が怠けちゃったら
会社の状況はもう分からないで
もう倒産してしまっちゃうんです
そこで発展しようとしてね
借金までして 新しい建物を買ったり借りたり
新しい機械やら入れたりするでしょうし
そうすると仕事はうまくいってもいかなくても
品物は売れても売れなくても
この借金の利息を払わなくちゃいけないでしょうし
銀行に だから もうやたらに会社を休んだりすることさえできないんです
まあ今頃なかなか品物が売れませんから
まあ 一ヶ月間ぐらいまあやめましょうと
休業しましょうと そうすると品物の数も減るんだから
まあそこそこ売れるだろうということもありますけど
じゃあ 一ヶ月間休業したらどうなるかというと
その 一ヶ月間でもう何百万円も
もしかするともっとたくさん利息とか何とかとか払わなくちゃいけないんですね
従業員に給料とかね そういうわけで
この幸福になるためにそんなことをやっても幸福にはならないんですね
とにかく苦しみしか残らないと
そこで理屈は 心は幸福はどういうものかと分かったことがない
見たことがない だから自分知ってる世界でこうあれば幸福じゃないかと思って試すだけ
もうちょっとお金あれば幸福じゃないかなと
なんとなく じゃあ試してみようと
もっと若い人と結婚した方が幸福じゃないかなと思って
じゃあ試してみようと試すんですね
試したところで全然幸福でも何でもなく
大変な新しい苦しみが生まれてくる
そこで病気になるのは嫌でしょうし
それで病気になることをやめるために
ありとあらゆる健康食品やら薬やらね
で 食べたり飲んだりするでしょうね
それで病気にならないかというと
結局なるのはもうお金がなくなっちゃうし
まあ薬にそういうものに体が依存するようになっちゃうし
どんどん体がすごい鈍感になって
病気になっても薬は効かないと
その代わりに新しい体の病気やら
いろんな新しい問題などが出てきたりするし
で そういうふうなことで
世の中の人々が 生命が幸福になろうではないかと探し求めるものからは幸福を得られない
理由は心が何が幸福かと分かってないと
このブッダの言葉というね
中村元先生 スッタニパータというパーリ経典を訳しているんですね
そちらをいろいろ大変古い少し経典ですからね
それなりに分かりやすい日本語に訳しているんです
で 訳はものすごい厳密に忠実に訳しようと
先生は大変な苦労をして頑張って訳しているし
でもそんなに暗く苦労したって
お釈迦様がおっしゃってるあの高度なメッセージは伝えてあげることはできないので
それにはすごい個人が勉強しておかないと
この読む人も誰でもね
で まあそれはしょうがないんだけど
一応経典はそれなりに厳密に
現代日本語に訳してるんですね
そちらにこのダニヤ・ゴーパーラという経典があるんです
ダニヤですけど カタカナでダニヤと書いていると思いますけどね
このダニヤ・ゴーパーラ・スッタというパーリ語では言いますけどね
今日はそのテキストは私は残念ですけど持ってきていないんですからね
あまり内容は言えないんです
ですからお読みになってくださいと
その経典の中でお釈迦様とある牛を飼って生活しているある人と互いに話し合ってるんですね
本当は幸福について喋ってるんです
二人とも全く正反対のことを言ってるんです
で 美しいのはこのパーリ語でその読む時なんですね
この言葉のものすごい微妙に言葉を遊んで言ってるんです
このダニヤさんがまず最初に「パッコーデノ ドゥッダキーロ ハマスミ アヌティーレ マヒャー サマーナ ワーソ」とか
まあもうすごい綺麗な言葉で言ってる 「
パッコーデノ」っていうのは
まあご飯は炊いてあるんだと
いわゆるもう食べ物はもうもう食事は用意しているんだと 「
ドゥッダキーロ ハマスミ」
まあ全部牛の乳を全部搾って置いておいたんだと
それから子牛たちをきちんと搾って
搾っていうか庭でね 搾って搾るって言うんじゃなくて
縛ってちゃんと置いておく
だから夜ずっと子牛たちが自由にあっちこっち走り回っちゃうと
まあ命も危ないし また飲みたい放題乳を飲んじゃったら
牛たちの子牛たちのお腹も壊しちゃうし
朝来たらもう搾る乳もないし
だから損ばっかしですから
先に子牛たちをきちんとあっちこち縛って
まあ母親の側に縛っておかなくちゃいけないんですね
それは全部やってるんだと
ですから 雨が降るたければどうぞ降れと
だからこれ詩です 雨が降るということは
このやっぱりいろいろ災難やらね
いろんなものが出てくることを象徴しているんですね
いくら強く雨が降っても
私は大丈夫だと ご飯はあるわ
乳は全部搾って置いておくわ
子牛たちがちゃんと縛ってあるわ
問題ないと それ縁縁と言うんですね
まあちゃんと窓もドアもきちんと閉まってあると
それから自分が高いところに自分の家を建てているんだと
奥さんのことは結構気に入ってるんだと
だから雨が降りたければ降ってもいいと
もう安心だと それは幸福論なんですね
そこで「パッコーデノ」 「
パッコーデノ」っていうのは
ご飯炊いて終わったという言葉で
お釈迦様が同じ言葉を借りて自分の幸福を語るんですね 「
アッコーデノ」 あの「パ」と「PA」の代わりに「A」だけ「P」だけ「P」抜けちゃう 「
アッコーデノ」という言葉を使うんです 「
ドゥッダキーロ」っていうのは
乳を搾ったということで
お釈迦様同じこと 「ドゥッダキーロ」と「ラ」と「ラ」ですね
皆様にあまりこの差がわからないかもしれませんだけど 「R」
の代わりに「L」入れちゃうんです 「
ドゥッダキーロ」の代わりに「ドゥッダキーロ ハマスミ」
ですから「アッコーデノ ドゥッダキーロ ハマスミ」とお釈迦様は答えるんです 「
パッコーデノ ドゥッダキーロ ハマスミ」という偈に
お釈迦様は「アッコーデノ ドゥッダキーロ ハマスミ」
ですからパーリ語ではすごく美しいんです
とにかく ほんのちょっとの言葉を入れ替えるんです
そこで意味が全く正反対になるんです 「
アッコーデノ」っていうのは
心の中でわずかな怒りもないんだと
わずかな嫌な気持ちも心の中でないんだと 「
ドゥッダキーロ」 「キーロ」というのは我々を刺しているいろんな矢みたいなものなんですね
私は全ての矢を抜けているんだと
この心 精神的にいじめられる
ありとあらゆるこの矢みたいなね
刺すものは全部もう棘抜いてるんだと
でも言葉同じなんです
ほんのRの代わりにL入れただけですごく意味が変わっちゃうんです
そこであの人がアヌティーレ
この川の一番高いところに私はサマーナ ワーソ
ずっと住んでるんだと言うんです
お釈迦様はアヌティーレ マヒャー エーカラッティ ワーソ
私はここにたった今日だけ住んでるんだと
ただ一日夜いるだけだと
それでお釈迦様も雨が降るならばどうぞ降ってくださいと
同じ言葉で全く同じバランスをとって答えるんですね
そこで牛がいるんだ 奥さんがいるんだ
気に入っている奥さんがいるんだということには
私には縛っておく牛もない
縛らなくちゃいけないと思う牛もいません
縛っておかなくちゃいけないと心配する窓もドアも家もないと
で 気に入ってて回らなくちゃいけない奥さんもないんだと
じゃあ私もそこ雨が降っても構いませんと
そういうふうにお釈迦様は心の安らぎ
心配することなんもないんだと
それで私は幸福ですよと
雨が降りたければどうぞ降ってくださいと
そこで幸福論を喋っていて
そこに苦しみのことも喋ってありますけどね
とにかく読みになったら
私が言っているところよりはものすごく幅広く
その問題をその経典で扱っているんです
何回何回読み直してみてください
すごく綺麗に扱っているんです
こういうことなんで 例えば家を作ったとする
それは幸福になるために家を作るんです
でも 作ってから家の中に楽しくいるよりは
家を守ることも大変なことになってしまっちゃうんですね
家のことを心配して心配してしょうがなくなっちゃうんですね
もし地震でもあったらどうしますかね
窓なんか閉め忘れ忘れちゃったら
外へどこかへ出かけたんだと思い浮かんだら
本当に窓閉めたでしょうか？と思い出さないと
もういられなくなっちゃうんですね
心配で だからこの何かもう納得いかないんですね
そこら辺では それでいいところっていうのは
人間の心は幸福というのは一度も見たことも味わったこともないんだから
まあまた同じ道で幸福を探そうとしているだけで
この不安さにはそんなに気がつかないんですね
でも心が知っている 頭が知らない
もし外へ出かけたところで
窓が閉めたかないかと思い
おそらく閉めてなかったとわかったら
心はすごく怖くて心配でビクビクするんですね
そこでお祈りでもするんです
どうか泥棒が入らないようにと
それでも祈りすること自体もすごい精神的に苦しんでいるということなんです
でも いつでも私たちはそういう道でいくんです
そこで時間すごくなくなりますから
早い早いスピードで で
第2番目のテーマに 幸福って一体仏教から見ればね
どういうものかと 簡単に説明いたします
本当に幸福というのは
この探し求めるものではないんです 100
万円探してるんだと そこで努力した結果 100
万円を儲かったとする
その100万円自体が幸福ではありません
もし本人がやっと100万円の貯金できたと
ああ よかったと心の中で幸せを感じるならば
その部分だけ幸福なんです
あの物ではないんです
ですから 幸福っていうのは
結局心のある状態なんですね
それで100万円から自分に幸福を作ってくれるんだと思ったら
それはもう何も作ってくれません
それは苦しみだけしか作ってくれないんです
家を作ったならば やっと頑張って家をできたという心に生まれる満足感が幸福なんですね
家自体はずっとその人をいじめて苦しませていくんです
[背景音楽]私たちが何かできたならば
頑張って頑張って何か得ようとする
その得ようとしたものは得たところで
なんとなくやっとできたとほっとするでしょうに
あのほっとする瞬間が幸福なんです
いわゆる満足感が幸福なんです
ですから そういうまあ
もう 100回離婚したっても
まあ離婚結婚するその瞬間だけでも楽しくまあなる可能性あった
あるならば その瞬間だ
結婚できてよかったという
あの瞬間だけ幸福 こんな瞬間なんです
そういうわけで この日常の生活の中で
我々は一生懸命頑張っていろんなことをするでしょうし
真面目に仕事をするし
それなりに家族の収入を得ようと頑張ったりはするし
それはものすごい限りない苦しみの道なんですね
でも そのやっている途中で時々ほっとすることができるんですね
それだけ幸福で それだけで人間というのは必死になって苦労しているんです
限りない苦しみを味わっているんです
子供が車一つ欲しいと言ったら
やっぱりそれを買ってあげたくなるんですね
でも 自分にはまだ貯金は足らない
で 親が一生懸命考えて苦労して工夫して
もうなんとか借金してお金借りて
会社からでも一つ買ってあげると
買ってあげたら このあげた瞬間で子供はすごく喜んで
車に乗ってどこかへ出かけたと
その瞬間で父親としてなんとなくああ
よかったと という あの瞬間なんですね
それからはその若者がこれはスピード出したりして
もう何やるかわからないし
それからすごく心の中でも火事なんですけどね
どうやることがわからないしね
スピード出すかもしれません
友達いっぱい入れちゃって
酒飲んであっちこちふざけてもうドライブに行ったところで事故を起こすかもしれませんし
家には全く来ないでもあっちこっち行くことになる可能性もあるしね
それからはもう心の中は火事状態にはなるんだけど
やっぱりそれでも買ってあげることできたと
という瞬間はほっとする
それだけは人間の幸福なんです
それでお釈迦様が考えるのは
本当に心が何か巨大な苦しみが消えた時
我々はすごく精神的に不安定で
精神的に落ち着きがなくてイライラしていると
何かがあって心が落ち着いたと
ほっとできたと ほっとすることができたと
あの瞬間で幸福であるならば
じゃあ何かその心はほっとすることできる
心が落ち着いていることができる
何があろうとも 心だけがすーっと落ち着いて平安な状態でいられる
何か方法ないかなと それだったら
それこそ純粋な幸福ではないかと
と思って我々に考え方を変えてみようととおっしゃっているんですね
あなた方はね 考え方だけ変えてみれば
一生ほっとして楽しく生きていられるんだと
ですから いつでも仏教は中道の答えを出しているんですね
例えば家があったら苦しいやと
奥さんがいると もう楽しみよりは苦しみが多いんだと
だから全部捨てろとかね
じゃあ捨てたら楽しいかと
そんなことは言ってるわけじゃないんです
もともと苦しいんだから
奥さんもらったし それで新しい苦しみが生まれたし
それで奥さん捨てたところで苦しみが消えますかね？消えません
苦しみが 2つになるので
もともとあった苦しみもあるし
それでもう捨てた苦しみもまたあるし
ですから 財産から苦しみが生まれるんだ
じゃあ財産捨てなさい
そんな簡単では答えられません
それは無知的な態度で極端的な道で
そうじゃなくて 第三番目の道
いわゆる中道という道があるんですね
幸福になるために 中道の道を教えるんですね
捨てろ つかめろではなくて
その中道的な道っていうのは
その心の考え方変えよう
牛いっぱい飼ったら幸福になるんだよではなくて
この心がほっとすること
落ち着くことをどうすれば落ち着くかと
どうすればほっとすることができるかと
そこを考えてみましょうと
その方法なんですね 幸福の道として教えているもの
それで幸福の定義っていうのはあれだけなんですね
心の落ち着き 心の平安
心で感じる あのほっとする瞬間
なんか大胆な感覚ではないんです
でもすごいそこだけは大事なんです
この大胆な刺激あることは幸福じゃないんです
例えば仕事に疲れたんだから
もうもうむちゃくちゃ酒飲んで
もう豚みたいにもう酒飲んで倒れるところまで飲んでやろうではないか
それはただの自己破壊だけで
あれで楽しみ 幸福を味わうことはできないんです
でもなくて 難しい仕事終わった瞬間でちょっとほっとします
それでじゃあ行って酒でも飲もうかなと
そう思える瞬間だけ幸福で
それから酒飲むとこからまた新しい苦しみがそこにあるんです
そういうことで心の状態だから
人間には二十四時間幸福にいられることは可能なんです
ですから その幸福を妨げている原因を探して
それを何とかした方がいいと
ちょっと時間的にはもう二時間も飛びましたので
ちょっと十分ぐらい休憩いたします
ちょっとニュアンスはちょっといきなり変えて
今日はいろいろたくさんいろいろ経典持ってきたんですけど
で お釈迦様が幸福 私たちは幸福だと言った言葉がいろいろあるんです
で そこで幸福についてお釈迦様の考え方はいきなり理解できると思います
そういうのは一応覚えてるものですけど
韓国ちょっと時間もなくなりますし
その偈文が法句経の百七十七
字が小さくて読みにくいかもしれませんけど
読み上げます ススカンワタジーワマ ヴェーリネーアヴェーリノー
ヴェーリネーマヌッセースー ヴィハラーマ アヴェーリノー
偈だから節もありますね
ススカンワタジーワマ ヴェーリネーアヴェーリノー
ヴェーリネスマヌッセーすヴィハラーナアヴェーリノというふうには我々も全部覚えていますけど
意味は今ススカンワタジーワーマ
ワタっていうのは確かにというね
ススカン幸福でジーワーマ生きてるんだと
それは日本風に言えば我々はなんと幸せだろう
我々はなんと幸せだろう
2行目ヴェーリノイス
恨みがある人々の中で恨みで苦しんでいるね
恨み 憎しみとかね 怒りとか
それどっちでもあります
恨み 憎しみ 嫌み そういう苦しみがある人々の中で
あ すみません ちょっと一言が抜けてます
あ  OK OK OK OK あの
怒り 憎しみある人々の中で
何の憎しみも怒りもない我々がなんと幸せだろう
で あの 日本語とパーリ語の言葉の順番が違います
逆だからね ですから ちょっとこちらから日本語で訳しなくちゃいけないんですね
怒り 憎しみある人々の中で
怒り憎しみがない 何の怒りも憎しみもない私たちがなんて幸せだろう
そこでまた同じことを自分の言い方繰り返して言うんです
ヴェーリネスマヌッセーす
恨みがある人々の中で
あるいは恨みがある世間の中で
人々の中でヴィハラーナアヴェーリノ
何の恨みもなく 憎しみもなく
ヴィハラーナ 生きているでしょう
我々は生きてますということ
それは一つの幸福を感じる瞬間なんですね
そこでお釈迦様は何言ってますかというと
人間というのはものすごく怒り
憎しみを持ってるんです
嫌な感じを持ってるんです
嫌だ嫌だと これでダメだとか
あれでダメだとかね それで必死になって戦ってるんです
仕事で戦う 生きることで戦うと
それで戦って負けそうになっちゃったら
本当に強力に怒ってしまっちゃうし
ほんのちょっとのことで
人間というのはすぐカッとなってしまっちゃうんですね
ちょっとあの儲けが少なくなっただけでも落ち込んでしまっちゃうんですね
そこで心の中で怒りが消えたならば
すごく幸せなんですね
そこでその幸せがお釈迦様は感じて
人々がつまらないことに限りなく苦しんでいる
どう見たっても苦しむ必要ないのに
で 例えばこのちょっとしたことで
家同士で恨みを持ってるでしょうに
国同士で恨み持ってるでしょうに
会社で同僚同士でいろいろ恨み持ってるでしょうに
そこで自分が誰かを恨んだりすると
自分のあの幸福という概念が全部壊れてしまうんですね
そこにあるのは苦しみだけなんですね
ですから ただ心の中でその恨みをなくせば
怒りをなくせば ものすごく心穏やかで平安でいられるんです
そうすると 人々がいろいろ苦しんだりしているのは
恨んだり 戦争したり 戦ったりしていることを見る瞬間で
あ 自分がなんて幸せだろうと感じることはできるんです
ですから 幸福っていうのは
お金あるんだから幸福
お金ないんだから不幸
一人でいるんだから不幸
結婚すれば幸福とかね
子供がいないと家族が不幸
子供がいると幸福とかね
そういうものではないんだと
おしゃれができれば幸福と
おしゃれができないと不幸だと
勉強できれば幸福で 勉強できなかったら不幸だと
そういう即的なものではないんです
本当の幸福は 勉強できてもできなくても
お金があってもなくても
美人であろうともなかろうとも
おしゃれができてもできなくても
なければいけませんね
人類はみんな幸福でなければいけません
もし会社の部長にならなきゃ不幸だと思っちゃうと
ものすごいバカバカしい考え方なんです
部長になるのはみんななれませんし
自分の状況でも頑張ればよろしいし
ですから部長になっても不幸な人は不幸なんですね
部長になるために限りない戦いをして
いろんな恨みを 人の恨みを買ったりした人がそうなったってももう不幸なんです
いろいろからくりして
自分が一番上のところに行ったと
例えば国の治める大統領みたいに
総理大臣みたいなところまでになったと
でもそこに行くためには
あれとあらゆる戦いをしてきたんだと
行ったならば その状況に至っても
いつ倒す 倒されるか いつ追い出されるか
蹴飛ばされるかわからないんですね
そこで幸福にはなれないんですね
ですから 心に怒りがない
恨みはない 誰も恨みません
すべての生命に対して何の恨みもなく
心穏やかな心を持つ 平安な心を持つと
その人にはずっとポーッとして生活することができます
それは決して金で買えない幸福でありますし
どんな人にも味わうことは可能な幸福でもあります
もし豊かさ 幸福だと誰かが言ったならば
あれほど嘘じゃない ないんです
なぜならば 豊かになれる
なれることは可能なのは
ある数少ない人間だけなんです
この物質的な豊かさっていうのは
ですから それでは幸福とは言ってはいけないんです
体がすごい健康ですよと
すごい健康な体あれば豊かですよと
幸福ですよと 美しく生まれれば幸福ですよと言ってはならない言葉なんですね
じゃあ美しく生まれなかった人はどうするんですかね
健康な体ではなくて 障害を持って生まれた人はどうしますかね
じゃあ頭がしっかりしている人は幸福ですよと
頭がしっかりしてない人々はどうしますかね
あんたは一生不幸でいなさいと言っては
言って言うんですかね
それはあまり良くない考え方
残酷な考え方 もし本物の幸福であるならば
すべての生命にそれできるようなものでなければいけません
動物の世界の中でも 互いに戦っている動物は全く不幸じゃないんですね
でも 落ち着いて平和で生きている動物たちが
それなのですごい幸福なんです
余計な苦しみがないんですね
ですから お釈迦様は当時で世の中見ていると
みんな互いに戦っている
戦っている あの人々の色が黒いと
我々の色が白い ただそれだけのことで戦争するんです
あの人の家柄は違いますと
我々の家柄とは違うんだと
ただそれだけですぐ戦っちゃうんです
それだけのことで で 皆様は事実のこと知りませんだけど
だいたいシェイクスピアという人がね
ロミオとジュリエットを書いたでしょうね
だからこのロミオとジュリエットのストーリーでも言っているのは
もう何の意味もない ただ
この家とこの家は敵同士
それは決まっているんだと
会ったら殺し合いしなくちゃいけないんだと
ただそれだけのことで家同士が戦うんだと
そこでもう恋ということをストーリーを作って
それは実らない恋になって
互いに苦しんで終わっちゃうと
だからそこにもその人書いているのは
怒り 恨み 根拠のない無意味な憎しみがどんな結果になるかということなんですね
ロミオさんとジュリエットさんがね
どれほどお互いに知り合っていたっても
最初は不幸で終わっちゃうんですね
大変悲しい不幸で終わっちゃう
そういうことで 恨み憎しみというのは
この人類を狂わしている巨大な苦しみ
不幸 ですからもう戦う競争の気持ちで仕事をしても幸福になれないんです
他人と恨んでも 他人と戦って他人を潰してやりますという気持ちで
どんな経済活動で政治活動をしても幸福にはならない
学校で勉強する時でも
他人と戦ってやろうではないか
競争してやろうではないかと
と ライバルを作って頑張ることは
あまりにも無知的な不幸な道なんですね
ですから そういうものをやめて勉強すればいい
ただそれだけ 誰かと戦う必要はないと
自分の仕事を真面目にやればいい
なぜ誰かと戦うんですかね
それあまりにも無知な不幸な人々というのは
誰か敵がなければ体が動かせないんです
今までのアメリカみたいに敵を作っちゃうんですね
ソ連を倒さなくちゃいけない
あの国を倒さなくちゃいけない
その人たちはアメリカにとっては偉大なる危険ですよとか
あれすごい巨大妄想概念で
ああいう妄想概念でアメリカは一生懸命固めてもう威張って頑張ろうとしているんです
だから 大きな力強い国になるために
もうすごい敵いいですか
なければ動けなくなっちゃう
だから突然このコールドウォーというものなくなったところで
アメリカはどうこれからどうしようかと
誰を敵に回そうかと という状態になってしまったんだから
それでいまだに誰かが敵がなければ
我々には正義の味方になって相手を倒すことはできませんということで頑張っているんですね
そういうのは幸福な道じゃないんです
ですから 敵は要りません
みんなお互いに仲良くして
お互いの幸福を願っていればいいんじゃないかと
私も幸福になって あなた方も幸福になればいいんじゃないかと
そういう道で幸福は成り立つんです
ですから お釈迦様は自分の心から全く怒りが消えて
何の憎しみもない 誰を見たっても何の憎しみも感じない
それでくだらない憎しみで互いに戦ったりしている人を見て
なんでこの人々はこんなに苦しんでいるんですかと
それで私たちはなんと幸福だろうと
とおっしゃるんですね
はい また同じ言葉 またいろいろ同じ似てる文がまた続くんです
あとですね ２行目だけ変えます
で 百九十八番目なんですが
ススカンワタジーワマアトゥレースアナサワアトゥレースマヌッセースヴィハラーマアナトゥラーアトゥレースアナサじゃない
ちょっと待って ２行目ちょっと間違えました
直してください アトゥレースアナトゥラー
アトゥレースっていうのはいろいろもう病気ということで
人間というのはいろんな精神的な苦しみ
悩みで いわゆる煩悩ばっかりあって
心がものすごく病んでるんですね
ですから まあ病人なんですね
この病んでいるこの人々の間で
私たちは何の病気も苦しみも悩みもないんだと
心に そういう私たちがなんと幸福だろう
アトゥレースマヌッセース
人間というのは まあ心の中でもありとあらゆる苦しみは悩み事はいっぱい溜まってるんだと
その中でヴィハラーメアナーソー心に何も悩みもなく我々は生きているんだと
だからそこが幸福ですと
そこで何を申し上げたい
お釈迦様おっしゃりたいというと
幸福っていうのは心に悩みがない状態
あれで悩んでいる これで悩んでいるという人が決して幸福じゃないんです
別に悩むことはないんだと
ただそれだけで私は悩みませんと
いかなることがあっても心が悩まない
そういう人が幸福ですと
それはどんな人にも育てることはできるでしょうし
金持ちになることよりは
どんなことがあっても悩まないようにいますよと
その心は作ることはできます
そうすると 誰でも幸福になれるんです
人は誰でも才能があろうともなかろうとも
背が高いか低いか それにも全く関係なく
どんなことがあっても悩まないんだと
落ち着いていますと それこそ幸福なんです
で 次のまあ  3番目 まあ時間がなくなるとやめます 28
番 ススカンワタジーワムジェーサンノーナッティキンチャナピーティバッカバディッサマデーヴァーアーヴァッサラヤター
ジェーサンノーナッティキンチャナ2行目
もう何もない 我々は何もない
持っているものは何もない
いわゆる囚われている
束縛されている 守らなくちゃいけないもの
そういうものは何もない
ものすごい自由 そういう我々はなんと幸せだろう
ピーティバッカバディッサマ
我々はただ喜びだけ栄養にしているんだと
喜びで生きているんだと
バッカっていうのは食べるということ
我々はピーチ喜びを食べてるんだと
自分の生きる支え 何ですかというと
喜び喜びで生きているんだと
ですから パーリ語で喜びを食べて成長しているんだと
喜びで生きているんだ
デーヴァーアーヴァッサラヤター
アーヴァッサラという天国
梵天の神々と同じだと
これすごい最高の梵天の最高と言っても一番最高じゃないんだけど
すごい高いレベルの梵天なんです
その梵天にいる神々がもう常に喜んでいるんです
喜びがそちらの栄養なんです
喜ばなくては生きていられない
人間の命を支えている栄養で言えば
一番分かりやすいのは酸素
酸素がなければ我々は死んでしまっちゃうんです
それでずっと我々は酸素を摂っているんです
それは喋っている時でも
寝ている時でも 酸素だけは取っているんです
たとえ数日のために麻酔
全身麻酔かけても酸素だけは取っているんです
そのようにこのアーヴァッサラ天国の神々がもうずっと生きている時は喜びだけは味わっているんです
寝ていても起きていたっても
それは関係なく 人間にとって酸素はどれぐらい大事かと
それぐらいアーヴァッサラ天国の神々にも喜びを感じることは大事な必要なものなんです
それがなくなったら死んじゃうんです
ですから このお釈迦様はお釈迦様の弟子たちも 24時間
ただ何を感じているかというと
ただ喜びを感じているだけ
それなぜかというと いろんなものを何もないんだと
そこで人間のことをまた言っているんですよ
人間が幸福になるために
ありとあらゆるものを集まるんです
この集まるものは結局迷惑の種になるんです
例えば 社会的な位置を獲得したら
それを守るために大変な苦労をしなくちゃいけない
ありとあらゆるもの その自分の位置にふさわしい生き方をしなくちゃいけない
結局 自分で自分の檻を作っているだけ
まあ幸福だから お金があるんだから
私はすごい高級な車買いますと
買った途端 車の奴隷になるだけで
座布団入ったらいけませんとかね
人はこれ触るなとかね
誰かがもうちょっと車貸してくれませんか？と言ったら
普通の日本車だったら
まあどうぞどうぞ乗っててくださいと
これすごい高級な外車なんかあったら
これ触ったらいけませんとかね
結局何のために買ったんでしょうかと
結局そういうことで 自分がそういう品物の奴隷になっちゃうんです
なんのことなくボロアパートに住んでるんだったら
友達は人来てもね みんなとゴロ寝して寝て遊んで帰ることできますけど
自分が最高級のところに住んでると
やっぱり一人が来るとその人を寝かせてあげることは大変なんです
ですから それで建物の奴隷になってしまっちゃうんです
そういうふうに人々がお金やら財産やらいろんなもの
家族やら幸福になるためにはいるんだけど
ただそれ自体が自分の足かせになってしまって
自由に生きていられなくなる
それで瞬間瞬間のことすることありますけどね
それで仏弟子たちにとっては何もないと
あ これなければ心配はとかね
そういうのはないんです
貯金しておかなきゃ心配だと
ちゃんと家を買っておかなきゃ心配だと
将来は不安だというバカげた考え方はないんです
人はいつ死ぬかわからないせんだから
いつ死んでもいいんじゃないかという
ただそれだけの考え方はないんですね
いつ死んだってもいいじゃないか
いつでも死ねるんだから
いつ死ぬかわかりませんだから
将来のためにと すごい苦労して貯金したっても
それを使う前に死ぬ可能性もあるし
そこで貯金してそれ使って始めたら
もし私は貯金全部使って死ぬ前に全部貯金使って終わったらどうしようかと
これ心配だと思ってまたケチをしなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから この人間というのは
やっぱりものによって幸福になると勘違いしているんです
本当はものによって名誉
知識 それはいろいろ得るものによって束縛されるだけで
心には何もなくてもいいやと
どうせ全部捨てるものだからという落ち着き
喜びさえあれば どんな人にも幸福になることは可能なんです
幸福はものから得るものじゃないんだと
学問的な知識から得るものじゃないんだと
社会的な地位から幸福になるわけじゃないんだと
お金とかたくさん友達がいるんだからといって幸福になるわけじゃないんだと
幸福は心の状態だと 心には何もなくてもよろしいとという状態を作らなくちゃいけない
お金があってもそれは構いませんだけど
お金の奴隷にはならない
お金があるならばいてくださいと
出ていきたいのじゃ どうぞ出て行ってくださいというふうな感じでいなくちゃいけないんです
別に困りませんと 子供が私は家出るんだと
はい どうぞと じゃあまた電話かけて
あの まあいるところないんだから
うちに戻るんだと はい
どうぞと どっちでもいいんです
子供が家出ようと また家に戻ろうか
どうぞ自由にしてくださいと
自分の心の安らぎを壊す必要ないんです
奥さんが喧嘩して実家に戻りますと
はい どうぞと言えばいいんです
で それに喧嘩する必要はないんです
で またうちに帰りますと
まああなたのことは心配ないんだけど
子供のこと心配だから
また私が帰りますと また言うでしょうに
ああ そういえばそうですね
どうぞどうぞと そういうのは
まあそれは冗談で言ったんだけど
やっぱり物事に囚われないようにすることこそ幸福な道
それは他人にも迷惑をかけない道
出ていくなと言ったら
その人の自由まで奪っているんですね
ですから 何もない状態っていうのは
何にも囚われてない状態
何にも束縛されない状態
誰にも自分の心の幸福を自分の心を奴隷にすることは不可能な心
そういう自由な心は どんな人間にも作られることは可能ですから
そういう幸福を仏教で本物の真の真の幸福だとおっしゃっているんです
そこで戦いについて お釈迦様はこういうことを言っているんです
ジャヤンウェーランパサヴァティ
勝った人は怒りを買うんだと
競争で勝った人がたくさん敵を作るんだと
怒りを買うってそういうことなんですね
恨みを買うんだと じゃあ競争に勝って恨みを買おう
勝ったぞと言張れないんです
競争で勝った人はたくさん敵を作っているんだから
それでドゥッカセティパラジト
もし競争で負けちゃったら
すごく落ち込んで苦しみますと
苦しみで落ち込んでしまうんだと
負けた人が だから競争で勝ったら負けで
負けたら負けで何もないんです
競争で勝つと必ず敵ばっかりでしょうに
だから敵の中できていなくちゃいけない
負けちゃったら自分には何の立場もなく
すごく苦しんで もう落ち込んでしまっちゃうんですね
じゃあウパサントスカンセーティヒットアジャヤパラジャヤ
この勝ち勝ちと負けと
その概念を捨てた人がこの世の中で勝ちでもないし
負けということもないんだと
勝った人もいないし 負けた人もいないんだと
みんな結局は負けの負け
負ける人々だからね 人生はみんな負けるんです
勝つようはないんです
ですから この世の中で私は勝つと概念もなく
負けるという概念もなく
落ち着いているんだと
ウパサント落ち着いている人がスカンセーティ大変幸福にいるんだと
ですから 幸福になりたければ
この競争の概念を捨てた
捨てて頑張ればいいんです
私は頑張ってはいるんだけど
誰と戦っているわけでもないし
誰にも勝とうとしているわけでもないんだと
誰を負かせをしているわけじゃないんだと
そうすると自分が負けても悔しくはないし
勝ったんだからといって敵を作ることもなくなっちゃうしね
ですから 世の中にあるこの競争原理は不幸の元だとお釈迦様の考え方なんですね
そこで人々が幸福がないということは
心がものすごく不安で燃えているんですね
人間というのは歩く火事なんです
山火事なんです もう動いている
山火事なんです 今日はすごく面白いことを見たんです
ここまでバスで来たんですけど
で こちらのバス停の前のバス停でバスを止まったところで
ある女の人がものすごい大きい声で叫び始めたんです
みんな驚いちゃった どうなったんですか？と
すっごくみんな不安な
どうなったんですか？と
なんかこのもう爆弾なんかの手りゅう弾なんかの引き金を引きて飲み込んだような感じで
ものすごくもう心配して叫んじゃって
どういうことかでそこで降りるんだそうです
あれちょっとあまりにも激しいんだから
ここでちょっとデモンストレーションすることはできないんです
もうとんでもない もうすごい声なんです
あれ どういう人かと思いましたけどね
あれでどうやって生きてるんですか
もし一番後ろにいたってもね
降りますって言えばそれだけのことで
これ叫んで降ります どうします？どうします？降りますから
降りますから 僕の頭に浮かんだのは
あの 何と言いますか 東海道新幹線に乗り乗り乗り遅れ人が間違って山形新幹線に乗ったような感じなんです
そうすると全く違う方向行ってしまっちゃいますからね
もし降りなくても次のバス停で降りれるんだからね
ちょっと 100 メートルぐらい歩くだけのことで
だからもう山火事なんです
ですから あのおばちゃんがいる家も幸福でしょうね
だから人間っていうのは歩く山火事
それで幸福になるわけじゃないんです
そこでその山火事は歩く山火事なんですよ
どっち？何が山火事かというと
ナッティラーガサモアギ
この欲ほどの火がないんだと
欲欲張り あれ欲しい これ欲しい
ああなりたい こうなりたいという
それで心がものすごく燃えているんです
それで幸福が消えてしまっちゃうんです
それでナッティドーササモカリ
怒りほど負けがないんだと
僕はこの前の講演でも怒る人が負けますよと言った覚えがあるんです
怒ってください あなたの負けだと
競争でどんなことでわずかでも怒ったら怒った人の負け
何のも才能ない 僕はその前すごいものすごい否定的なことを言ったんですね
間抜けで腰抜けで 何も才能ない
頭が悪くて まるっきりの大馬鹿者で
そういう人が怒るんだと物事に
智慧があって 知識があって
能力があって 物事をうまくできて理解できる人が
どんなことがあっても怒りませんと
ですから それほど激しく言ったのは
わずかでも怒ってはいけませんということはもう説得力あって言うためなんです
でもそれは説得力あるただの言葉ではなくて
本当なんです 負ける人はもう腰抜けで
もう負け犬で もう才能ない
全くの無知なんです 怒る人は
それでお釈迦様はそれを堂々とおっしゃっているんです
ナッティドーササモカリ
一行だけがあります このカリっていうのは負け
損 怒りほど負けがないんだと
ドーサっていうのは怒りですね
ナッティっていうのはありませんと
ドーサ怒り サモっていうのはイコールという
怒りに等しい負けがありませんと
怒りほど負けがありませんと
人生 たとえわずかなことにでも怒ってみてください
それで負けたと その勝負はもう自分が負けてるんです
いかなる場合でも怒ってはいけないんです
怒らない人はいつでも何らかでどんな問題も綺麗に乗り越える
それでナッティカンダサマドッカ
この体ほど苦しみがないんだと
体は全部苦しみだと 体を五に分けてましてね
身 受 想 行 識と五つに分けているんです
体と心が その体と心というのは両方もうただ苦しみだけだと
ナッティサンティパランツカン
そこでサンティ シャンティというよく聞こえている言葉でしょうに
平安な心 平和 だから平安な気持ち
平安な気持ちほど幸福がありません
ですから 心に欲がない
怒りない 欲がないと 欲がないともう火事ではないんです
怒りがないとどんなことにも負けませんし
体は大変苦しいものだと
心もただ苦しいものだと思ったら
体と心にも執着することがなくなっちゃうんですね
心配することはすべて消えちゃう
それで心は平安になる
あれ心配 これ心配と腰のことを心配やと膝のことを心配だと
ああだこうだ体のことを心配心配と
もういくいく自虐なんですね
そんな体はどうせ苦しみものだと
子供のことを心配だ 財産のことを心配だと
将来のことを心配すると心が苦しんでいるんですね
どうせ心も苦しみだと思った人には
体と心に対する執着が消える
そこで平安な心が生まれるんです
それほど幸福がありませんと
それから次に もっとわかりやすいことをおっしゃっているんです
アーロギャパラマーラパ
イティッティ 最高の徳
徳というのは損得の得
損得の得 最高の得 儲けはアーロギャ
健康であること 健康な人はもう最高の得を得ているんですね
よく得しているんだと
それは得の中で最高だと
これは損得の得なんですね
サントゥッティパラマンダナ
サントゥッティ 喜んでいること
あ よかったと あるいは満足していること
それは最高の富であると
最高な財産はあなたは喜んでますかということなんです
私は人生はだいたい喜んでいるよと
もう満足しているんだと
ということが言えるならば
その人はすごい金持ちなんです
すごい豊かなんです ものすごい財産ある人なんです
ですから 本当に財産ではないんです
心で 心で心に喜びを感じるならば
それはもう財産です そこで最高の親族って誰ですかね
信頼できる人 もし信頼できる誰かが一人でもいるならば
その人こそ本物の親戚親族だと
ですから お釈迦様はまあすごい厳しいんですね
ただおじいちゃんがいるんだ
おばあちゃんがいるんだとかね
あんまりそこは切りみしません
母親がいる 父親いるんだとかね
でも自分には信頼できる人がいるんだと
何でも言える 何でも任せる
何でも頼られるというふうな一人でもいるならば
それはその人の最高な親戚だと
それはすべて幸福の方法なんですね
そこでパラマンスカン最高たる幸福は涅槃であると
他のものは一つも幸福ではない
最高のものではない ですから
最高たる幸福は涅槃でありますと言ってますけど
なかなか瞑想させたっても
涅槃は体験したくないという気持ちがあるんだからね
それはどうしようもないんです
私には それでもう一つ幸福になることがあります
サーフダッサンマリアナ
心を清らかにしている人々と
心はすごく清らかにして落ち着いている人々と会うことも幸福だと
なぜならば 心幸福になる
清らかになることは幸福なんです
ですから 普通の燃えている
火事で燃えている人が
まあ心が燃えてない人が見ることだけでも
その人にとって幸福だと
ただ その影響で自分の火事がちょっと抑えます
ですから もし私たちにこの心を清らかな人々が見ることでもできたならば
それは素晴らしいと サーフーサンニワーソーサダアスコ
もしそういう人と付き合うことをできれば
どういう人？心を落ち着いて清らかにした人と仲良くすることができれば
それはサダアスコ永遠に幸福だと
アダッサンエーナバーラナンニッチャメーワスキーシヤ
この愚か者どもと 愚か者っていうのは毎日混乱だけで
怒りだけで 苦しみだけで
他の脳がない 金儲けはあーしようこうしようとか
それしか脳がない そういう人々から離れて聖者と付き合うことを見ることさえもできれば
まあなんと幸福でしょうということなんです
まあ幸福なことはあるわあるわ
もうたくさんあります
そこで我々はこの幸福になりたければ
お釈迦様は言うのはできるだけこの愚か者を避けましょうと
愚か者っていうのは我々に苦しみを作ってくれる人々なんですね
ちょっとしたことで緊張して叫んだり喚いたりする人々一緒にいると
自分も乗っていないとさらに燃えるんですね
さらに爆発するんですね
だからその人の怒りに乗ったところで
こちらも苦しいんですね
まあまあまあ落ち着きなさいと言っちゃったら
もうこちらは殴られるかもしれませんね
そんな落ち着いていられますかと
また向こうは怒っちゃうし
ですからもう幸福になりたければ
そういうもう歩く火事を避けた方がいいんですね
避けて自分が落ち着いていればよろしいし
ですからそこはすごく言っていて
ディーランチャパンニャンチャバフッサンチャ
知恵のある人 よく勉強して知識が深い人
ドーライヒャシーラン
よく努力する 怠けないで努力する人
それから心の汚れを全部捨ててしまって
心を穏やかにした人々
そのような賢者と付き合いなさいと
それで幸福になりますと
とにかくそういう全部言ったのは
この幸福の定義がこの心の落ち着き
心にある このほーっとする瞬間
それは幸福であるということで
それから 幸福になりたい
どうすればよろしいかと
と人が質問されたとする
幸福になりたい どうすればいいんですか？それで心穏やかにしなさいというふうなことだけでも足りません
なぜならば 人間にはいろいろことをしなくちゃいけない
家族があるならば 家族を守らなくちゃいけない
家族に家族の人々に食べるものがないんだと
私は落ち着いているんだからいいんじゃないかと
そんなことを言っていられる場合じゃないんです
子供は病気になって死にかけているんだと
でもまあいいや 私は落ち着いているんだから
これいいわけないでしょうに
それで ですから ただ心を落ち着け
それは幸福やという風に言うだけで
物事済むわけじゃないんです
自分の会社が倒産したと
別にいいんじゃないか
私は落ち着いているんだからと
だけどそれからあなたはどうやって生きてるんですかという問題もそこにあるんです
だから何ですか ローマがね
火事になったっても ネロがバイオリンを弾いていたんだっていう
まあそういう生き方はもう正しい生き方じゃないんですね
それでもし質問されたら
どのように幸福になれますかと
お釈迦様は中道だから
順番で丁寧に幸福になる方法を教えちゃうんですね
まずというのは 愚か者と付き合うのはやめよう
知恵のある人々と仲良くしなさい
どういうことかというと
人間というのはいつでも人から学ぶ
心には人から学ぶことはどうしても避けられない
自然に我々は環境によって育てられる
どうしようもないこと
ですから 自分がいつでも知恵のある
頭のいい 心は大きい 滅多なことに驚かない
感情的にならない 失礼を起こさない人々と仲良くする
それで心がどんどん育てていく
次にプーチャチャプージャネーヤ
尊敬するべき人々はちゃんと尊敬しなさい
頭を下げるべき人にちゃんと頭を下げなさい
謙虚的になれということ
余計な屁理屈言って人間みんな平等だから
なんで私は先生に礼をしなくちゃいけないんですかとかね
そういう話喋ってる人々は
まあただの歩くゴミであってね
粗大ゴミで生ゴミでね
もういるところも臭いんですね
ですから なんで親を尊敬しなくちゃいけないんですかとかね
その話よくこの現代社会で聞こえますけど
私もああそうですねと聞いてるんですけど
僕はやっぱり臭いんだとね
歩くゴミだと 生ゴミだと思っちゃうんです
なぜかというと そう思って
私はそれに影響を受けないようにする
なぜかというのは もうどうせ歩く腐ってる生ゴミですから
自分 私たちは親がなければここにこの世の中にいるわけじゃないし
先生たちやらいろんな人々がいろんな行儀やら仕来りやら正しいことやら教えてくれたんだから
なんとか無事に生きているし
それだったら正しい道を教えてくれる人々
私たちのことを心配してくれる人々
私たちのモデルになるべき人々にちゃんと礼をして
頭を下げて謙虚的な心を持たないと
その人々から追い出されるんです
そうすると 自分には幸福になることはできないんです
ですから 尊敬するべき人々はちゃんと尊敬しなさいと
それから自分にふさわしい場所に住みなさいと
私はここで生まれたんだからと
私は日本人だからといって
ある一箇所にとどまったり
しがみついている必要はないんです
地震でそこら辺 自分の村がね
完全に消えちゃったならば
そこの他のところに行かなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それで一生苦しんで悩んでる必要ないし
とにかく人々っていうのは自分の才能能力を発揮できる場所があるんです
そこに引っ越ししなくちゃいけないんです
もし素晴らしく英語を勉強したならば
子供誰もいないすごい遠い田舎に行っておばあちゃんたちしかいない村に行ってもお金にはなりませんね
それおばあちゃんたちに私も何か仕事をしたいんだけど
じゃああんた何かできるの？英語はできますけどと言ったって
おばあちゃんちはまあ結構ですけどねと
別にもうおばあちゃんたちには英語なくてもね
今まで歳までは英語なしでなんとか生きてきたんだからね
残りの歳もそれできますよってことになるでしょうし
もしすごく英語を習ったならば
その仕事を生かせる場所で自分が生活しなくちゃいけないんです
それで自分が豊かになるんです
ですから この自分の能力を生かせる場所を選びなさいと
それからよく徳を積みなさいと
やっぱりいいことをやっぱりしておかないと人生危ないんです
いつでも たとえわずかでもいいことをしておくと
何か万が一何かあっても
その人だけを守ってくれるんですね
やっぱり やっぱり やっぱり会社の人々をリストラにしたんだと
この人はよく人を助けてくれるわ
いろいろことをやってくれるわとに
というと やっぱりこの人はいくらなんでもよく役に立ちますから
やっぱりリストラから外しますよということになっちゃうんです
ですから とにかくいいことをしておくと
そうすると幸福になる
それから自己コントロール
自分の感情をちゃんとコントロールする
ある内面的な落ち着きですね
怒りたいんだから怒るとかそんなことはなくて
叱りたいんだから叱ったぞとかね
そういう無責任な生き方ではなくて
心の中はできるだけコントロールして抑えておく
それからよく勉強する
よく勉強しなさいと 知識を得なさいと
知識得るだけじゃなくて
何か仕事を身につけなさいと
いわゆる能力が 知識も得ること
いろんな仕事的な能力を身につくこと
それから道徳を学ぶこと
正しい生き方を学べ なぜならその道考えたっても
ものすごく勉強している知識人ですけど
全く道徳がないと誰もそちらに行かせませんね
誰も 素晴らしく勉強しているんだけど
生き方はすごく怪しいんだと
それだったら子供たちを任せませんね
先生お願いします 教えてくださいと
何を教えるかわかりませんだから
何するかわかりませんだから
ですから いくら頭が良くてすごい勉強していたっても
本人には道徳がないと不幸になってしまっちゃいます
ですから 知識と一緒に道徳も必要
同じくすごい仕事できるんだったら
やっぱり道徳それでも必要なんです
ですから 勉強と能力とプラス道徳
それ３つ揃えないと幸福にならないんですね
それから喋る場合はいつでも清らかなことを喋りなさい
分かりやすい言葉 美しい言葉を喋らなくちゃいけない
次に自分の両親を大事にせなさい
両親の恩をちゃんと覚えておいて
両親がどうせ年取りますから
両親には子供しか頼るものはないんです
ですから 両親の面倒は必死になって見なくちゃいけないんです
みんな現代社会だから
あまり気にしない 両親のこと
まあ嫌ですよと 別に恩なんかは全然感じませんと
と言われると どうなるんでしょうかね
自分を育ててくれた両親に対しても
何の感謝もない人に仕事を任せられますか？その人を信頼できますか？その人なら私のことはよく面倒見てくれるだろうと
その人だったら国を任されます
任されますよと なぜならば
親が死んでも見なかったと
親がもう寝たきりになって
体中汚くなって 面倒見る人もなくて
苦しんで飢えじめになったんだけど
この息子が一度も見落としなかったんだから立派な息子ですよと
だからいい仕事を任せちゃうと
なるんですかね そんなことは
ならないでしょうに そこで会社辞めてでもすごい大事な仕事ある
それなのに申し訳ないんだけど
両親が寝たきりになったんだ
ですから 私は会社辞めますと
辞めて親の面倒見る それぐらいの性格ある人だったら
もう必ず幸福になります
なぜならば それぐらい恩を知っているならば
この人にわずかなちょっとことしてあげたら
この人は必ずそれを倍にして恩を返してくれるんだと
だからその人を助けてあげようということになるんですね
ですから 仏教ではもう両親のことをちゃんと大事にしなさいと
それで自分の性格ができているかないかという
自分が立派な人間かないかと見る尺度
そこにあるんです 親と喧嘩するかしないかということで
親の面倒見るか見ないか
まあ親もできてなきゃ難しいんだけどね
そこでプッタダーラーササンガホ
自分の家族をちゃんと養いなさいと
それからやりやすい仕事を選べと
かっこいい仕事ではなくて
やりやすい仕事選びなさいと
そういう風に人生を幸福にする
落ち着いている人生を作る
それから中年ぐらいになりますから
いくらかもう貯金もありますからね
家族も養って 簡単な仕事をして
やりやすい仕事をして
それからダーナンチャ
寄付したり 人々を助けたりして社会的な状況を作るんです
もう寄付したり 援助したり
そういう活動をする人々には
仕事を終わっても社会では立場があるんです
ですから そこまでしなくちゃいけない
そういう社会援助やら寄付やらお布施やら
そういうことをする それからダンマチャリーヤという精神を育てる道
法を実行する 真理を実行しようとする
年取ってきたら他のやることない
仏教を勉強して それは実践しようと見るしか方法ないんだからね
それやろうとすると そうすると
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちを必ずも孫たちに尊敬されるんです
孫たちをいじったりして面倒見たりしないんだから
できないことをやめちゃって
自分が清らかな道を歩んでいるならば
それはもうみんなの役に立ちますね
ですから 年取ってくると寄付したり
人を援助したり 助けてあげたりしながら
自分が法を学んで実行しようとする
で それから親戚の面倒も見てあげると
親戚に対して関わり方がいろいろありますから
年取ってくるとそれは上手にできるし
わかるし 責任もあるし
それはちゃんとやらなくちゃいけない
で とにかく何も悪いこともしないでくださいと
わずかでも悪いことをしてよくと
いつ自分がひどい目に遭うかわからないんですね
自分の名誉がなくなってね
立場がなくなる ですから
冗談ででも悪いことをしない方がよろしいと
それからすべての罪をやめること
酒をやめること 酒 麻薬
アルコール そういったそういうのをやめること
それで健康がなくなって
頭も悪くなって不幸になるんだということなんですね
で 怠けないこと やるべきことはすぐすぐすぐやって終わると
で 大変この謙虚で それから自分の生き方について喜びを感じていること
満足すること 恩を知ること
今まで自分もいろんな恩を受けて生活してきたんだから
こういう人は私にこういうことをしてくれた
あの人はこういうことをしてくれた
あの人はこういうことを教えてくれたとかね
そういうのはよく覚えていて
恩を知ること で 仏教を聞くこと
世の中で頭をしっかり育ててくれる教えが他にないんです
まあそれはもう断言して言えるんだからね
まあ下らない話はいっぱいありますけど
カーレンダンマサワナ
説法を聞きなさいと 法門
聴聞ですか 法門すること
聞法 仏教の教えを聞くと
もうものすごくみるみるうちに智慧が発達するし
お釈迦様と付き合ったことにもなるし
すべての幸福はもう出てくるし
それから修行してみる
世俗的な仕事終わってくると
じゃあ修行でもしてみようと
修行に励む 瞑想に励む
ブラフマチャリーヤ 出家の真似事でもしてみる
佐伯にずっと家に束縛されているんじゃなくて
家のことはいくらかこう落ち着いて
落ち着いてきたら 自分が心からでもいいんです
心からでも家のことから離れて
旦那やら奥さんやらそういうところから心は精神的に離れて
この清らかな道 出家の真似事でも
まあ一日 二日 週間 一日だけでもね
そういうことを頑張ってみると
それからお釈迦様おっしゃったこの苦の真理
すべては苦であると すべては無常であると
それはどういうものかと自分で体験してみようではないか
さらに修行に頑張ると
瞑想してみると やがてその人が世の中で損があろうか
得があろうか 名誉であろうか
不名誉であろうか うんと貶されようか
褒めようか どんなことがあっても
心が穏やかで 何ものにも取らない心が最後に作るんだと
我々は褒められると舞い上がる
貶されると落ち込む 損得をするとすごく舞い上がっちゃう
損をするとすごく落ち込むという心でしょうね
それは幸福な心じゃない
世の中でどんな風に回転しようが
心は穏やかにすること
そのようにすべての悩み苦しみをね
どんなものが起きても
地震が起きようか 火山が爆発しようか
ものすごく儲かろうか
自分の庭で油田でも出来上がろうか
自分のもう家ごとに爆発して飛んでいこうか
まあ落ち着いていると
そのような落ち着いている心は最後に作ると
最高な幸福なんです それこそ最高な幸福だというふうなお釈迦様は順番で人々に幸福の道を教えているんですね
だから 誰にも何の迷惑のない幸福の道なんです
何も損することはない
子供から 家から 奥さんから苦しみがあるんだから捨てろというふうに
単純なことを言っているわけじゃないんです
きちんとした知恵の人間になれと
それは赤ちゃんの時からちゃんと計画立てなくちゃいけないんですね
すごい計画的に生きていればいいんです
ですから 小さい時は勉強する
勉強できるときは思い存分ありとあらゆることを勉強する
だから僕らにしても出家しているんだからでって
出家に関わることだけ私が勉強したならば
説法丸っきりできないんです
僕は世の中にあるくだらないものを何でも勉強する
何でも読んでみる 探ってみる
別にすごいという感じは全然しません
なんてアホくさくてくだらないかとずっと感じますけど
それでも勉強する そういうことで皆様に説法できるようになっているんです
そうでないとお釈迦様のその言葉は現代人にわかりやすく解釈できるという
それものすごい難しいんです
これ 大学でも学者の先生方がいるんだけど
ほとんど不可能なんですね
現代人にわかりやすくアピールできるように
しっかりと心に響くように喋るということは
ですから やっぱり勉強する
しておくことも一つの生きる道なんですね
勉強だけじゃなくて 何かできなければ
この先週で亡くなったスリランカで最高なレベルのお坊さんが１０２歳で亡くなったんだけど
コンピューターを習ったのは９０歳なんです
ものすごい知識人で 学者で
この歴史的な出来事をミャンマーでしたんですね
1956年か 55年かと覚えてないんだけど
この全部パーリ聖典をこのまた結集みたいに集めてパーリ聖典を読み上げて新しく出版したんです
すべて ですから この第6結集という
このテーラワーダ世界では歴史的な出来事なんです
すごいお金がかかる仕事で
ミャンマー政府がやったことなんで
そちらのあのプレジデントとしてプレジデントのお坊さん何人かいたんだけど
この亡くなったお坊さんも一人でいたんです
ですから ものすごい知識人で
すごい凶悪なお坊さんでもすごい人なんです
それでもよろよろの体の時でも
自分がいろいろ仏教の本書いたり
文章書いたりしているんだから
まあこれは便利だと思って
今まで手で書いていたんだけど
それでもコンピューターのまあ習ってみようと
全部それ習って もうそれからはコンピューターでちゃんと本書いてるんです
ですから もう９０歳になっても
やっぱり明るく頑張って
もうその時までも元気でしたけどね
ですから このたくさん勉強する
たくさんいろんなことを学ぶ
そういうことで 我々のしっかりした生き方
計画的になるんですね
まあ大体そういうことで人々は幸福になります
ですから あの 本当の幸福は何ですか？と言えば
答えは簡単 心の落ち着き
心にほっとする感覚 心配することないんだという感覚は本当の幸福
それは得られるために
まあきちんと計画を立てていかなくちゃいけない
それでまとめて言うならば
きちんとした知識的な生き方
知恵に基づいた生き方こそが幸福の道なんです
感情的な生き方じゃないんです
世の中みんないい いいと言うんだからいいわけじゃないんです
自分でちゃんと判断して生きるということは
知恵こそ知恵こそと仏教ではものすごく言ってるところまたあるんです
まあ見つかりません で
とにかく知恵で知恵の生き方は幸福の生き方なんです
まあ一旦まあそこら辺までということにして
またいろいろ言いたいこといっぱいあります
それからあの幸福だけじゃなくて
どのようにすれば不幸になって堕落するんですかと
それもいくらか知った方がいいと思います
どのように堕落するんだと
堕落する人々というのは
この簡単に分かりますと
この人は堕落してもう不幸になるんだと
ダンマカームバワンホテダンマデッシーパラバオという言葉がありまして
真理正しいものを知りたい人がもう成長して幸福になるんだと
真理は何で正しいものなのか
どうでもいいやという人がもう最初からもう諦めた方がいいと
ですから 我々のこれ気持ちなんですね
自分が本当のことを知りたい知りたいという気持ちがあるならば
やがて本当のことを知ることはできるんです
まあそんな全部いんちき臭いとかね
私は見たくないんだと
嘘やとか ああだこうだとかね
まあどうでもいい生き方をする人々は
まあそれでも不幸になるんです
ですから もし幸福になりたければ
それだけ気をつければいいんですね
まあやっぱり本当のことを知りたい
本当のことを調べたいという心の目覚め
いつでも守ると 次に また同じことの繰り返しなんですけど
できてない人々を好きだったら
いわゆる悪い人々 性格の悪い人々
乱暴な人々を見たらものすごく気に入っちゃう
それだったら私も危ないと気をつけた方がいいんです
で 学校をさぼる人々と仲良くしたくてしょうがないんだったら
その子供は自分のもう将来は終わりとそこで決めなくちゃいけないんです
それは子供たちに教えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
あなたの将来はどうなるかは我々わかりませんと
でも もしあなたのあなたが学校をさぼったり
悪いことをしたりする子供たち
友達の方が好きだなと仲良くしたいという気持ちがあるならば
将来は決まったもんだと
ですから 嫌ででも強引にでもちゃんと真面目に勉強する友達と仲良くしなさいということを言っておかなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 私たちはこの何か心が引く
何て言いますか 引かれてしまうんですね
ある人々に その自分の心が自然に悪い人々に
道徳ない人々に できてない人々に引かれてしまうならば
自分の心の根本が危ないんです
自分が根本的に危ないと
ですから それだけ気をつけてほしいと
それで世の中の道徳的な教えではなくて
まあくだらない漫画とかね
単なるもう何の役にも立たないものとかね
そういう話とかね 勉強したってもどうでもいい勉強とか好きだったら
その人はもう堕落しちゃうんですね
やっぱり何か役に立つためになるものを勉強しない
好きにならなくちゃいけない
次に簡単なことを言うんです
随分寝ること好きだったら
睡眠にふけうんだったら
いつでも寝ると 電車に乗っては寝ると
会社に行っては寝ると
家に帰っては寝ると 学校に行っては寝ると
いつでも寝るという 寝ることだけ
自分の休みがあったら 1 日中寝ると
それいつでも寝る そういう性格の人は成長しません
寝ることだけ 仏教は随分悪口言ってるんです
それでサバーシーレ あまりにもこの人々とこの社交的で
みんなとしゃべるはしゃべるは仲間作って仲間と 1 日中いろんなもう仕事じゃなくていろんなことをやって楽しがっている
ですから このグループ作って
そのグループの中に入って
そちらといることだけ楽しがっている人は成長しない
しゃべる好きで遊び好きで
ですから いつでも誰かがいないと落ち着かない
誰かが呼んで あるいは誰かの家に行って
まあ 2人3人でなんとか 1 日中遊んでいるとかね
そういう性格の人はもう堕落するんだと
それから頑張らない人は堕落するんだと
やっぱり努力しなくちゃいけない
常に それから怠け者は当たり前でね
怠け者は堕落する それからすぐ怒る人が怒る性格
ちょっとしたことで怒る
それで一番悪いのは 心の中で怒るのはまあしょうがないかもしれませんだけど
怒りを表現する いわゆるすぐ怒って何か言う
すぐ嫌な顔をする 嫌な態度を取る
なんかすっごくなんかもう野生の動物がハリネズミみたい
もう誰も近寄れない そういう人々もいるんですね
これはいかん これわざと文句ばっかりとかね
そういうふうに文句言う人も怒りですからね
その場合だったら もうなかなか成長しない
ですから 怒ることで人は堕落する
怒る心の中で怒っても
すぐそれを抑えて表現しないようにしなくちゃいけないんですね
それでまた堕落することをまた前と同じことを言っているんです
もし誰かが自分の父親母親がすごく年取って年老いて落ちこぼれていると
老いこぼれていると それで誰も面倒見る人がいないんだと
それでも自分が自分の両親を無視するならば
もう堕落するんだと 自分には財産もある
まあ財産なければしょうがないんだけどね
面倒見ることもできる
また 他の誰か両親の面倒見てあげる人もいない
それなのに放っておくんだったら
もうそれ一流の悪人なんですね
ですから その人は堕落するんだと
そこでこの真理を教えてくれる人々
宗教家ですね 自分にはきちんとこういうこういうことで
こういうことだと教えてくれる人々を騙してはいけません
嘘を言って それで自分には何も教えてくれなくなっちゃうんですね
で 最後に一番面白いことを言うんですね
あまりお金もないんだけど
欲だけは大量にあるんだと
それでその上 この あの
何といいますか シャトリア職
シャトリアカーストに生まれるというのは
王様たちのカーストで生まれるんだと
王家で生まれると 王家の人で生まれて
あまりお金もない でも欲だけはすごくあるんだと
そこで自分もいつか王様になりたいと思うんだと
それで人生は不幸になるんだと
それはどういうことかと
当時のことなんですけどね
でも今もその精神的な問題はあるんです
で なぜ私にもできないかと
例えば会社に入る 新入社員として
で 社長やら誰かが見たらすごいかっこよくて見える
ものすごい高級な車があったり
すごい贅沢な家があったりとかね
ああ 私も同じ会社の社員だからなってやるぞと
と思ったっても 才能やらいろんなこと必要なんですね
ですから そういうものがついてるならば頑張ってもいいんだけど
ただ単に好きだけで 恋しいだけで
欲しいだけで危ないんです
好きだから好きですよと
それでは物事もうまくいきません
自分にはそれ獲得できるかないかと
例えば ある女の子が 16歳で 10億円も儲かっているんだと
だから私も 16歳だから頑張って儲からなくちゃと
それはやめた方がいいんですね
それはそれなりの才能がある人はそうなるんであって
才能ない人にはそうはなれないんですね
時々そういう風に精神的に病気になる場合もあるんですね
同じ仲間の中でそれできちゃうんですね
例えば 学校の同じ学校の同じ何何同士
同級生でほとんど知識も全部同じだと
でも一人が随分いろんなことをして成功しているんだと
かなりお金の回りがよろしいと
見たら やっぱり自分も同じことをやらなくちゃいけないと思ったら
その人の人生不幸になる
ですから そういう他人のことを見て
ああいう風になりたい
こういう風になりたいと思う
あれは精神的な病気 自分になれるところまでなれればいいんです
ですから 昔お釈迦様がこのシャトリア族の人々がたくさんいたんです
だからシャトリア族の人は王になるんだけど
自分には財産ないと 王になろうと思っちゃったら殺されるんです
反逆者とかなんとかと言って
あなたは王様を殺して国を滅ぼしたではない
ですから いくらシャトリア族であっても殺されちゃうんです
で もし自分にはすごい財産があったならば
自分で自分なりの軍隊なんか作って戦ってでも
自分でも国を一つ作ることはできます
人の国の一部でも取ることはできますけどね
暴動でも起こしちゃってでも
でもそれには財産が必要なんですね
ですから お釈迦様はすごく明確にこのシャトリア族に生まれて
それでお金もなくて その上すごい欲張りで王にもなろうとしたら
それは堕落の道だと それは我々現代風に解釈しなくちゃいけない
いくらかは資格があるんだけど
あるんだからといって
他の人々と全く同じくなるということはない
ですから それを覚えておけば
人々は幸福になる そういう風に我々は堕落する方法もあります
で これから一応テーマ以外で喋りますけどね
一応また 1ヶ月半ないんだからね
まあ全部喋ります それ